Could Elvis be destined for the deserts
of Arrakis? Just ask Austin Butler,
whose iconic drawl doesn't seem
to be going anywhere anytime soon.
"But in the end you gotta listen to yourself.
So I want you to know those New York
people ain’t gonna change me none."
The Golden Globes returned on January
10th to celebrate the 80th anniversary
of the all-encompassing entertainment award
ceremony. This year, the Golden Globes awarded
well-deserved television and film nominees such
as the side-splitting gem Abbott Elementary,
legendary Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever actress Angela Bassett,
and the dazzling star Austin Butler for his
show-stopping performance as Elvis Presley.
"Mumbling incoherently to the
audience was a good show?"
"Colonel, I know when I've excited an audience."
Butler's faithful portrayal of
Elvis skyrocketed the success of
Baz Luhrmann's biopic with a near perfect
audience score on Rotten Tomatoes. This
launched the film to an impressive global
box office take of $287 million among
the summer's competitive slate. With one
award already under his glistening belt,
it's safe to say he now has an even better
chance of securing the Oscar in March.
"Everything’s happening to me so
fast in the last year and a half,
I’m all mixed up, you know, I can’t keep
up with everything that’s happening."
When Butler came onstage to receive his award for
Elvis, his voice sounded astonishingly similar to
the beloved musician, using a rich baritone
and slight twang that's reminiscent of his
film portrayal. As it turns out, the actor has
some surprising thoughts about that resemblance.
Speaking with People magazine, Butler broke
down the parallels between himself and Elvis,
and offered some explanation as to
why they might sound similar. He even
detailedk the meaningful relationship
he shares with the Presley family,
which culminated in his authentic
representation of the iconic star.
Backstage at the bustling award show,
Butler told reporters that he doesn't
hear Elvis in his own voice. However, he
didn't shoot down the possibility that
the performance has stayed with him,
given how long he spent playing Elvis.
"I had three years where that
was my only focus in life,
so I'm sure that there's just pieces of my
DNA that will always be linked in that way."
Butler has been open about his special
connection with Elvis that led him to the
part. The acclaimed actor also expressed
his gratitude and thanked the Presley
family for their blessing and encouragement.
All you have to do is comb through social media
to find a ton of comments from fans that point out
how different Austin Butler's voice has been since
Elvis. And in fact, his recent interviews aren't
the first time the actor referenced it. Butler
previously addressed the vocal similarity on his
Saturday Night Live debut in December 2022. During
his opening monologue, he spoke about how people
have been talking about his alleged new voice.
"That it got deeper, more Elvis-y. But that's
not true. I've always sounded
like this, and I can prove it."
He then transitioned to an interview clip
from 10 years ago — with one small change.
"How excited are you to be
Sebastian on The Carrie Diaries?"
"I'm really excited. It's been
a great experience so far."
It's clear he's willing to have some fun with
his fame, and any criticism that may come his
way. But will Austin Butler's voice ever go
back to the way it was? Only time will tell,
but one thing is for certain: With
Butler slated for a role in Dune:
Part 2, it sure would be interesting to see
an Elvis impersonator turn up on Arrakis.